from Death by duffel bag to drugged up
Cubs cocaine bear has all the Mad cap
energy and wackiness its title suggests
believe it or not it only gets more
bizarre from there
in most cases the first scene should
properly set the tone for the rest of
the film and as you might expect cocaine
bear does it with some Gusto we open an
unappropriately wagged out fashion with
a drug Smuggler named Andrew C Thornton
kicking cocaine filled duffel bags out
of a plane not only is he super kicking
Coke duffels like Shawn Michaels but
he's also dancing while he does it this
lets the audience know that this is not
a film that needs to be taken seriously
by immediately establishing its mad cap
tone the scene concludes when Thornton
clunks his head on the door and falls to
his Doom as early enough for this part
of the film is somewhat factual to real
life events minus the coke field dancing
we think the real Andrew Carter Thornton
II was a real-life narcotics officer
turned drug Smuggler operating out of
Kentucky the film even shows archival
news footage of the actual events right
before we go into the fictional
narrative much like the duffel bags of
cocaine this scene effectively drop
kicks you into the bare Bedlam to come
bear get cocaine cocaine bear kicks off
with a scenes trades out of a Friday the
13th movie two Taurus hikers enjoying
the Splendor of The Great Outdoors while
an unseen threat lurks nearby we meet
Olaf and his wife Elsa enjoying their
nature walk while discussing their
upcoming wedding it's here we gets a
humorous bit of dialogue where Elsa
bluntly tells Olaf she doesn't want his
brother's band playing at the wedding
following this squabble with a couple
spots the titular bear emerging from the
trees most of their immediate Intrigue
Olaf begins taking pictures before both
of them realize that the bear isn't
acting right writhing around and
head-butting trees before Olaf and Elsa
can even blink the bear begins
approaching them with apparent malice in
its eyes they are then attacked by the
bear who proceeds to drag Elsa away to
her death right in front of a horrified
Olaf after the bear mauls Elsa it lets
out to Roar before the film's title card
drops on the screen the title disappears
and the bearers immediately distracted
by a pretty butterfly which she chases
off-screen it's a glorious first kill
that samensa film's dark sense of humor
while also establishing momentum and
zone for the rest of the film
following cocaine Bears first gruesome
murder we are treated to a decade
appropriate Montage of drug public
service announcements among these PSAs
are two particularly noteworthy ones the
famous this is your brain on drugs
commercial and an anti-cocane PSA
starring Pee-wee Herman these
over-the-top PSAs help to immerse the
audience in the anti-drug sentiments
that were rampant in the 80s during the
decade politicians adopted intense
anti-drug platforms introducing things
like the Dare campaign and slogans like
just say no that this is your brain on
drugs commercial features a frying pan
with some hot grease meant to represent
brain altering substances we then see an
egg introduced to the pan as a not so
subtle metaphor for the dangers of using
drugs it's definitely silly but nothing
will ever hold a candle to Paul Reubens
in character as Peewee talking about the
dangers of crack cocaine well definitely
a noble goal Peewee might not have been
the best fictional character to trot out
for that particular message it's a
bizarre yet hilarious little addition
and a nice dose of nostalgia for anyone
who grew up during the anti-drug
messaging of the 80s early on in the
film were introduced to Dede a young
artist who wants to paint the Rocks near
a waterfall unbeknownst to her mother
DeDe and her friend Henry have skipped
school and ventured off into the woods
on their wholesome little hike the kids
discover a lone brick of cocaine in the
bushes and decide to pick it up Henry
begins lying that he does cocaine with
his other friend all the time leading DD
to call his bluff what ensues is a scene
where two unaccompanied children do Coke
by eating it off a pocket knife this of
course does not work and both kids
immediately spit out the cocaine before
continuing their hike to the falls they
then discover another brick of cocaine
but this time it appears as though
someone or something had already gotten
into it this is revealed to be the bear
who then makes its presence known
terrifying both DD and Henry as the
saying goes don't do drugs kids and
these particular kids learn this lesson
in the most hilarious and frightening
way because drugs especially cocaine are
very very bad one of the strangest
things about cocaine Berry so the bear
itself doesn't it's every act of
violence in the movie Yes in this world
we're shown that human beings can be
just as violent and destructive as drug
adult Bears early on in the film The Two
drug dealers named David and Eddie
arrive at the park in search of their
buses lost cocaine upon arriving David
Goes to use the bathroom where he is
confronted by a trio of punk teens it's
mentioned just before this scene that
these teens have been causing trouble
around the park most of the Chagrin of
Liz the park ranger these teens very
foolishly try to shake David down for
his money and has subsequently boot
stumped for it the feed continues
whooping the teens from Pillar To Post
leaving them all knocked out on the
bathroom floor this scene is brutal and
hilarious and a perfect example that
completely bear free Anarchy and
violence also exists in this movie
crucially it also establishes that these
dealers are a formidable Force setting
up the inevitable showdown between them
and the Bear
part way through the film Dede's mother
sorry Ventures to the park in search of
her daughter and Henry she tags along
with Liz and an eccentric Park inspector
named Peter to locate them after
venturing deeper into the woods the trio
eventually finds Henry scared out of his
mind and halfway up a tree it's not too
long before the bear re-emerges
horrifically wounding lives before
turning its attention to a hysterical
Peter while fleeing from the bear Peter
crawls for his life through some bushes
before landing face first in another
pile of lost cocaine he then takes a cue
from Henry and proceeds to climb another
tree while sari hides behind one this
leads to a very tense moment when sari
just barely avoids the Bear's detection
and as Coke fueled wrath while Henry
believes they will be safe above the
ground this turns out to be a tremendous
mistake because Bears can climb trees
enticed by the scent of the cocaine all
over Peter the bear rushes up the other
tree and begins violently eating him why
is it acting like this did you feed a
cocaine after bailing on sorry Henry and
Peter Liz returns to the Park's main
building machine counts as remaining
young teens who had encountered David
previously both of them equally battered
and Bruce have no idea about each
other's situations with Liz assuming
that scenes were also attacked by the
bear this calls for some paramedics
before they notice a noise at the door
which is revealed to be the Bear in a
moment of panic Liz discharges her gun
and accidentally shoots one of the teens
through the head this leaves one
remaining teen who notices along with
Liz that the bear is gone but there are
now noises coming from the roof while
the film wears his absurdity proudly it
should be credited for this scene and
the following one as they showcase a
decent amount of suspense before belting
you upside the head with a bear attack
this tension isn't broken when the bear
crashes through the door's mini window
and begins clawing the teen the horrific
scene left behind sets up the moment a
little later on when the Medics arrived
to investigate the Carnage a short while
after the bear at Saxon Park's main
building two paramedics arrived examine
the crime scene the paramedics Beth and
Tom Venture inside where they find a
complete bloodbath with Liz barely
clinging to life many of you might
recognize comedian Scott sees from his
Tick Tock videos mourinhi often
relatedly comments on the annoying
pitfalls of retail work you just lost
yourself a customer you think I own this
business Tom checks out a bathroom that
appears of blood pulling out from under
its door for Beth checks on Liz right on
cue the bear reveals itself to a
horrified Tom who attempts to close the
door and quietly leave before the bear
brings it down on top of him now trapped
under the door Tom attempts to escape as
Beth Lowe's and injured Liz into the
waiting ambulance Tom is able to free
himself on board the moving ambulance
before the bear gives Chase easily able
to keep up with the fleeing vehicle what
ensues is a ridiculous Chase sequence
where Liz attempts to shoot the bear as
Tom attempts to shut the door to the
ambulance the scene reaches its
Crescendo when the bear jumps through
the air and lands on the back of the
ambulance mauling Tom and sending Liz
flying out bath then meets a gruesome
meant when she crashes the ambulance
into a tree that's a film nears its
final acts the two remaining storylines
converge at the bear's cave where Didi
is being held sorry and Henry arrive
finding Dede hiding in the cave after
following a trail of paint and left
behind for them to track this coincides
with Eddie and David joined by Eddie's
dad Sid who's played by Ray liosa also
traveling to the cave to reclaim more of
the Lost cocaine both parties make the
same shocking Discovery the bear has a
set of cubs that are also hooked on
cocaine much like their mother the Cubs
are hopped up on a healthy Blizzard of
the white stuff with their fur even
covered in it later on in the climax Sid
Ops to play save the curbs by throwing
them another sizable brick of cocaine
definite credit to the film's marketing
team who wisely chose to keep this
additional twist out of the trailers and
it makes for a nice surprise for
audiences it also ensures that the bear
is in just a one-dimensional drug-fueled
villain and gives some extra Stakes for
the film's big finale
cocaine bear reaches its epic conclusion
where all truly great films should on
the edge of a cliff sorry and the kids
have now held at gunpoint by Sid not
keen on letting any Witnesses get away
at the same time Sid begins needlessly
beating on the Cubs for trying to nibble
at his reclaimed cocaine his comeuppance
soon arrives in the form of the Cub's
Mama making a grand entrance on the top
of the waterfall before jumping down to
the Cliffside to protect her babies at
this time sorry the kids Eddie and David
all opt to jump off the cliff and into
the waters below to escape Sid is able
to temporarily fight off the bear before
accidentally gifting her with one final
dose of cocaine as he had sensory claim
a bag dangling from the fools in one
final last-ditch effort Sid becomes tied
up in the strap of the bag Sid then
begins choking as the bear slashes his
gutzhouse which a curb them proceeds to
eat considering this is Ray Liotta's
final on-screen performance following
his death in 2022 this was one hell of a
way to go out it also caps the insanity
of this movie nicely and cocaine bear
remains bizarre and Brilliant right to
the very end
[Music]